[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le nouvel an chinois s'apprêtent en
effet à être célébré mardi prochain les
gars ont donc rempli de voyageurs qui
partent rejoindre leur famille 2022 sera
placée sous le signe du tigre d'eau est
synonyme de changement imprévu mais
aussi de rébellion les relations
humaines pourrait gagner en progrès
gagné en profondeur en objectivité et en
transparence quel serait votre première
décision concrète si vous êtes élu
président de la république
bonjour cher julien il n'y aura pas dans
l'état actuel des choses de premières
décisions puisque macron va être réélu
dans l'état actuel des choses les
puissances financières qui sont emparés
dans notre pays l'ont déjà décidé c'est
l'actualité du week end quelle est votre
réaction à la victoire de christiane
taubira à la primaire citoyenne abel a
enfilé la chaussure qu'il avait été
préparé pour elle je suis pas concerné
j'ai été inscrits d'office dans une
élection à laquelle je ne voulais pas
participer et par conséquent n'ont pas
de commentaire cela vous appelle à
l'union de nouveaux jeux super bonne
idée pauline glissons vous êtes
d'ailleurs devant le qg de christiane
taubira le seul où une réception est
organisée façon soirée électorale et il
ya de l'ambiance
je n'entends pas
tellement d'ambiance que pauline buisson
ne nous entend pas un mot sur la
primaire qui a désigné donc christiane
taubira quelle est votre réaction une
candidate de plus cette eau c'aurait pu
être un moment de rassemblement et de
rang rassemblement de toute la gauche
pour une candidature unique c'est une
candidature de plus elle a dit qu'elle
allait vous appelez elle ne renonce pas
à faire l'union de la gauche une
candidature de plus est-ce que vous êtes
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
peut être voir berre
regardez jamais exigea mais je crois si
je sors dans le pays a desire suffissant
si je sens une volonté si je sens un
appel je serai prendre mes
responsabilités laure delahousse oui
c'est une vraie formule ou regardez bien
on a fait un petit test ah oui c'est
bien c'est pas mal oui c'est bien bien
un truc comme ça le mec pas trop content
de lui juste qu'il faut juste qu'il faut
oui franchement je suis content parce
que je crois que ça doit être la seule
photo où je suis présente après je suis
petit
chez-soi j'étais des photos j'étais moi
je sois je me touchais le sixième
chapeau
quelle est votre part de féminité
je crois que je suis métrosexuels j'aime
bien me préparer j'aime bien mignon
ok ok mais pas tous les jours
aujourd'hui ah oui vous êtes là
catherine maire de personnes m mais de
mon côté j'ai vu tom cruise se retourner
il a pris ses cliques et de vestiaires
pardon dégringolé non pas dégringoler il
a pris il a pris son ticket de vestiaire
et il avait une banane autour de la
taille non mais moi oui y avait une
panne avec un smoky à la la
moi j avais même pas je sais pas à temps
c'est pas fini valerii mais le ticket
dedans et là elle est quoi la faire la
fermeture est coincé allez je te jure
j'avais envie de lui dire tu peux pas
faire ça moi je t'ai vu tu accrochés à
des avions en plein décollage
qu'on voit vraiment chez elle c'est que
au niveau de ses joues c'est comme un
petit peu rentré un peu pincé il ya des
lignes au niveau de ses joues ça c'est
le système gynécologique en fait qui
encombre et avec jusque là
bas les détails ce que je pourrais
demander un kleenex parce que vous avez
je suis assis la bouteille d'eau
j'ai plus à l'est ll derrière tout
mouillé mais c'est que les excuses de
l'eau ne marchera pas cette fois comme
un pas qu'ils ont un goûteur je suis
très affecté par plusieurs choses
d'abord par la plainte
la plainte la plaignante dit que mon
mari a essayé de l'embrasser dans une
piscine en 2013 voilà la teneur de la
plainte voilà ce dont est ce dont est
accusé mon mari cela m'affecte
évidemment on est dans une émission il
ya beaucoup de sentiment d'émotion moi
je me sens pas bien je trouve ça
pathétique je suis désolé pour vous
mais c'est quand je me sens pas bien je
suis très très dur très très sévères je
suis papa quand l'autre est content
quand l'autre est heureux j'ai c'est
super j'ai par exemple quand je suis
chez moi et que je regarde votre
émission et que ça pleure trouve ça
ridicule
je trouve ça dérange pas ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que tout cela m'affecte
nous affecte et que je voudrais terminer
là dessus sur le fait que ça affecte
également la promotion de mon livre or
moi je ne suis pas dans les médias
toutes les cinq minutes comme tout le
monde ni comme mon mari moi je n'ai pas
d'émission moi j'écris un livre c'est
toute ma vie ce livre c'est toute ma
jeunesse où loge à faire et il est déjà
difficile de faire de la promotion en
temps normal et ça l'est encore plus si
c'est pour ça groupe dont les questionne
sur votre mari est il possible de faire
confiance à une personne qui sont porte
aussi facilement pour diriger la france
avec diplomatie c'est au bain dans
l'indre qui nous précèdent je vois qui
est des gens qui me connaissent de très
près puisqu'ils savent que je m'emporte
facilement s qui ne confondent pas
s'emporter ce passionné
joe et c'est parti
en fait partie
j'étais inquiet le trois-bassins vous
aviez le feu nucléaire on arrive
non mais vous avez raison une fan non
mais caroline où il faut bien voir une
chose il ya une boîte à faut pas la
confondre avec la boîte à thé et vous
l'ouvrez il ya plein de boutons alors si
c'est le jour où vous n'êtes pas chez
vous appuyez sur tous les boutons et ça
déclenche une guerre nucléaire écouter
s'il vous plaît pas ce roman l'homme
dans cette cellule se plaint du dos un
rapide coup d'oeil quelques palpation
[Musique]
l'examen dure moins d'une minute l'homme
est apte à être entendu
pour cette prestation la généraliste et
payer 50 7 euros 70 par l'état
elle va enchaîner quatre consultation
express c'est comme ça tous les jours un
jour ma mère a demandé deux francs à mon
grand père pour lui faire acheter de la
viande est à 12 ans j'en ai pleuré et je
lui ai dit maman je ne parlerai plus à
mon père mais tu manqueras put jamais ta
vie d'argent voilà et c'est là où j'ai
compris où c'est là je pense que je suis
devenu un homme et c'est là où je suis
parti un petit peu dans la délinquance
j'ai dû me faire arrêter sans mentir en
garde à vue sans exagérer peut-être
allez on va dire mille fois
[Musique]
rien que l'année dernière l'état a versé
150 mille euros à sept médecins
mises bout à bout ces consultations
médicales pèse 12 millions d'euros sur
le budget de la justice
melton de moi vous êtes de tricheurs sur
nos sociétés
s'il vous plaît
laissez-nous entre juifs c'est bon
[Rires]
quel moment d'une journée désigne aussi
la région sud de la france
la tahiti